i'll never forget sitting in the car on
the way home i was in the middle i had
asher here and shy here guy's hand was
on you that was so cute on me and then
he kept looking at asher to make sure
that he was okay
i know it's unbelievable what babies
understand there are times where i feel
like i can't even handle one
how am i going to be able to handle two
under two i think i won four in total
holy cow
first of all i'm so glad to be with here
with you in person in the flesh it's
been a minute i've been a minute since
i've been spoken virtually before so
this is pinch me i know i know so you're
here in la with your mom girls trip our
first girls trip how has it been talk to
me a little bit about it amazing yeah
it's fun because i'm older i can drink
with her i can afford to do the thing
okay
no babies no alex i love them but i need
a break you know mommy needs a break so
i brought my mommy for a girls trip i
love that so alex is at home with the
boys
how is that going i haven't gotten any
calls that are like from the hospital or
anything thank god okay so i know we're
good he sends me pictures
i had to change asher and bathe him
because he had a blow up diaper twice
okay and sends me pictures to show me
yeah that asher had a blob diaper oh
goodness this is payback though for the
israel trip oh yes i mean i'm not here
for
eight days but i'm living my best life
here yeah give your brother a kiss
oh
good job
okay
so good when i first talked to you about
this show one of the reasons you said
you wanted to do it is because it's like
having footage you know home video
footage for years in the future to watch
back
that moment that wasn't even like staged
or set up of course
what's interesting is shine knew there
was a baby in mommy's belly we would
tell him your baby brother your baby
brother and he would rub my belly and
then belly wasn't there but baby wasn't
home so we went to the hospital to get
him
shy knew
who that was and the fact that he went
over to him look i've got chills he went
over to him and gave him a hug and gave
him a kiss like he knew
yeah and he just wanted to grab him he
thought it was a doll
what has surprised you the most about
their brotherhood so far
i mean i i guess i didn't know what to
expect
because some people like they're going
to be best friends or some people or
like they're there's going to be
jealousy
shy is so protective over him yeah he
just wants to play with him
and every single morning every single
morning
asher i sure would walk over to the crib
and asher has the biggest smile on him
ready for his brother it's the best it's
amazing i hope it stays like this but
i'm not gonna get my hopes up
that's the thing that scares me like i
don't want to be too mommy-like like i
still want to be fun and laugh and wear
crop tops and do things you know i don't
want to forget who i am you mentioned
that you have a fear of losing yourself
being a mom of two boys where are you
with that do you feel like that has
happened or have you found a balance
well i cut my hair i look good thank you
i judged myself instead of the mom bun
all the time
um i'm still finding that balance
because
having two pandemic babies right you
don't adjust to you're not rushed into
having to go back to work and send the
kids to school like i was very lucky i
could have them at home but then i got
scared taking shy out and finally i
adjusted to it and then asher comes
along and i have to start all over again
and how do i go out with two i don't
like a hermit so i'm just adjusting to
that i'm definitely going crazy i'm not
gonna lie yeah because i'm at home with
two babies you know and i'm talking to
them as if they understand me
and then i use my baby boys to alex and
he's like okay all right baby voice is
off well you've been working on finding
your mommy circle of friends
i love what i love about you and alex is
that you're so open and real so other
mothers who might feel similar to you
can relate and learn so how has that
process been with finding mommy friends
not easy it is hard to make friends as
you get in general in general yeah right
like i know this is gonna be hard to
believe
i mean we've interviewed a few times i
was very social growing up and now that
is not hard to believe at all i'm a
hermit and i don't know how to make
friends but then you have this common
interest kids right right but
when you're with other mommies
you don't want them to judge you or give
advice or this or that and you don't
want to be the mom that's like oh maybe
you should do this or i would never do
that you know what i mean but i do i
have mom friends now good
yay
we don't know if south florida is really
what we want i don't know if that's
really a smart choice this is america
everybody moves all the time another
huge topic this season was the
possibility of you moving yeah alex and
the boys moving your mom look her face
right now i was like i'm like
she's also my realtor okay so is she
open to you moving out of state now
because that was something she was
against is she still against it
absolutely is that gonna stop me
probably not that was my follow-up
question
okay so are you moving
i don't know okay it's definitely open
for discussion yeah and you'll have to
see what happens okay that makes me feel
like a season two is coming i don't know
okay i'm just on there you know i'm just
sharing my life with you
and my kids and my husband and you know
me finding myself yeah something i want
to ask you i always see in the comments
that youtube brings such positivity and
love to reality tv
how do you take that on you know how
does that feel nice it is nice but you
know when you're always getting
complimented
do you actually sit there and take that
in what people are saying how you
influence lives for the better i do
because i still don't believe it i'm
just me and lauren i'm a daughter i'm a
mom i'm a wife i'm a friend
and i'm a hard-working person so when
people tell me
i'm their inspiration i have to pinch
myself i've literally taken a step back
and said
wow
like i would never i look in the mirror
and you know i don't see that because
it's me
but i know i have a platform and i knew
from day one that i want to use it for
good
like you said i'm a real person i've
documented making friends not having
friends opening up about my struggles
with tourette's syndrome or finding
myself right it's important because i'm
just me yeah
it's really nice to hear it though i'm
not gonna lie
well we grew up in ukraine i know alex
grew up in ukraine yeah i don't mean to
bring a damper no it's okay but i'm but
i'm curious how how what are the
conversations you two are having how is
he feeling with everything going on over
there he has family there still
and he even said i didn't think it was
going to affect me as much as it did
and it's still affecting him he
i don't want to say that our our tone in
our house has been depressing it's been
sad it's scary for sure because this is
real
i mean
he grew up in ukraine and then grew up
in israel and those are two spotlight
countries
and it's hard but we do talk about it
and it's very important to talk about it
instead of bottle it up yeah very true
very true well speaking of alex we know
he wants another baby he wants two
actually
so find somebody else honey how's he
convinced you to make this happen soon
or what
he's very good at what he does he does
this jedi mind trick right so he'll say
lauren
you want to have a mommy makeover right
yes i do so don't you want a mommy
makeover oh yes like a full oh hello
hello goodbye yeah
so that would have to be after the fact
though right well that's what he says
right you know
you were working out so hard to get your
body back to then get pregnant again
just think about you can have a mommy
makeover sooner than later
he's so
right and i hate that he does that
but he knows how to get to me you know
how to get to him too though yeah but he
always gets what he wants
always so that must mean
that soon it's a possibility it's a
possibility okay well with everything
that happened with baby asher
the
complications all of that is it safe
for you to
yeah we've talked to the doctor he
obviously said wait towards the end of
the year you know
but only time will tell it's hard
leaving the hospital because
we're going home we just had a baby and
we're going home without him
and it's like okay so now what
well there were so many
heartfelt moments this season tell me
what was your hardest moment to watch
back
my hardest moment was honestly
watching the hospital right and the
delivery i remember living through it
and then
i honestly don't remember the hospital
experience because i was so medicated i
didn't have the easiest delivery and
then the easiest easiest experience so
they kept me drugged which was great but
then looking back on it like wow i
really went through that
it was not easy not being able to see
asher not knowing
there was a picture alex had sent me
because i was stuck in the room
and asher was you know laying there with
tubes and pipes and i screamed and
nurses came running in they thought i
fell
i didn't know like that was my baby i
couldn't help him
it was the hardest thing to do and i i
hope that people who do have to go
through it can take from my experience
and know that they're not alone and to
accept the help
and talk to people who have been through
it too because it helps
yeah so that's your biggest piece of
advice if you are experiencing something
like that there's somebody else who's
done it too
and it's okay to be like talk to me tell
me i'm gonna be okay yeah yeah i love
that it's true okay put him
down let's see what he goes to
go
to england
oh my goodness
okay well one of my favorite moments
this season is when you and alex came
back from the baby moon and you wanted
to see who shy would walk up to first
that was so real because i don't have
kids yet but i could imagine
myself doing that with my husband
so cute so what was one of your favorite
moments from this season
or the number one
the number one aside from having asher
and seeing the boys meet alex getting a
pedicure really that was a big deal for
you it was a big deal because for years
i'm not getting one i don't like one oh
no no
now the man loves it yeah so i love the
fact that i was like i told you so so
this is something he does regularly now
no but he needs a new one he needs like
a revamp of those
laws on his feet
[Music]
you